Shure: 啊看我笑的多灿烂啊
Shure: Ah, look at my bright smile.
Shure: 啊我又暗淡了
Shure: Ah, now I'm back to being dull.
Shure: 老板知道为什么我暗淡了吗
Shure: Boss, do you know why I look so gloomy?
Jack: 因为没给钱是吧
Jack: Because you didn't get paid, right?
Shure: 因为我想涨工资
Shure: Because I want a raise.
Jack: 啊
Jack: Ah.
Shure: 可以了可以了可以了
Shure: It's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Katrina: 慢点慢点慢点慢点慢点
Katrina: Slow down, slow down, slow down, slow down.
Jake:准时
Jake: On time.
Shure: 懂懂
Shure: Got it.
Shure: 这叫什么
Shure: What do you call this?
Shure: 音乐脱口秀
Shure: A musical talk show.
Shure: 懂了吧
Shure: Got it?
Jake: 可以
Jake: Sure.
Alice:你这状态持续多久了
Alice: How long have you been like this?
Jack: 这是有有病
Jack: There's something wrong.
Jack: 有病得治
Jack: You need to fix it.
Katrina: 你弹的够悲伤的
Katrina: You play so sadly.
Nicous: 妈的 跟着修硕这节奏
Nicous: Damn, following Shure's rhythm.
Shure: 有一种
Shure: There's a kind of...
Shure: 怎么我的诗朗诵不好吗
Shure: What's wrong with my poetry recital?
Katrina: 特别好都想哭了
Katrina: It's so good that I want to cry.
Jack: 太好了
Jack: It's great.
男嘉宾:关了
Male Guest: Turn it off.
Shure: 我都不知道难忘今宵的歌词是啥
Shure: I don't even know the lyrics to "Unforgettable Tonight."
Jake:就就这个
Jake: It's just this.
Shure: 难忘今宵
Shure: Unforgettable tonight.
Shure: 我们大家一起大合唱
Shure: Let's all sing together.
Jack: 我们来点年头小点的吧
Jack: Let's sing something a bit newer.
Alice:哈哈是吧
Alice: Haha, right?
Shure: 年头小点的歌
Shure: A newer song.
Shure: 怎么你你哈哈哈
Shure: Why are you... hahaha.
Jack: 哎这个可以可以
Jack: Hey, this one is good.
Alice:我俩坐那吧
Alice: Let's sit there.
Jake:难忘哈哈哈
Jake: Unforgettable, hahaha.
Alice:你把凳子搬过来呗
Alice: Move the chair over here.
Katrina: 他改精神攻击了
Katrina: He's switched to mental attacks now.
Jack: 你就会这一句是吧
Jack: You only know this one line, right?
Shure: 对
Shure: Yes.
Jake:不行了不行
Jake: I can't take it anymore.
Jake:你还要加工资
Jake: You still want a raise?
Shure: 什么
Shure: What?
Jake:你还要加工资
Jake: You want a raise?
Shure: 对啊
Shure: Yeah.
Jack: 这应该 是后经也损人位是吧
Jack: This should be after the damage, right?
Shure: 大家有有什么想听的歌吗
Shure: Does anyone have a song they want to hear?
Shure: XBZ都会弹
Shure: XBZ can play them all.
Nicous: 我会库吗
Nicous: Can I handle it?
Nicous: 哎呀这终于恢复正常了
Nicous: Ah, finally back to normal.
Nicous: 来来来找个什么歌唱什么
Nicous: Come on, let's find a song to sing.
Shure: 唱什么
Shure: What to sing?
Shure: 你刚才说什么
Shure: What did you just say?
Shure: 不会
Shure: No way.
Jack: 看起来可以唱
Jack: Looks like we can sing it.
女嘉宾:真的很会唱啊
Female Guest: Really good at singing.
Jack: 能唱就唱
Jack: If you can sing, then sing.
Shure: 给大家表演一个
Shure: I'll perform for everyone.
Shure: 每次都会在酒后给大家表演的
Shure: I always perform after drinking.
Shure: 叫什么来着哈哈
Shure: What's it called again, haha.
Shure: 对
Shure: Right.
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Let's go.
Alice:本人不伤心
Alice: I'm not sad.
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Let's go.
Alice:试这个点心
Alice: Try this snack.
Shure: 就四个和弦
Shure: It's just four chords.
Shure: 你往低了点弹不就得了吗
Shure: Just play it a bit lower, won't you?
Shure: 哎呀我都能
Shure: Oh man, I can...
Shure: 弹到哪了
Shure: Where did I play?
Shure: 就1645四个和弦
Shure: Just 1645, four chords.
Shure: 我我我我我怎么怎么起的啊
Shure: How did I start it?
Shure: 哎怎么怎么卧槽
Shure: Oh, how, oh crap.
Jack: 我又寡言掉了你懂个叫我行不
Jack: I lost my train of thought again, can you help me out?
Shure: 我我我我最啊我最爱
Shure: I, I, I, my favorite...
Shure: 卧哎卧槽
Shure: Oh, oh crap.
Shure: 哈哈哈等一下
Shure: Hahaha, wait a second.
Alice:气急败坏
Alice: So flustered.
Shure: 啊啊啊找到了
Shure: Ah, found it.
Shure: 谢谢大家谢谢大家
Shure: Thank you, everyone, thank you.
Alice:你喝酒不喝
Alice: Are you drinking?
Alice:我给你拿杯子
Alice: I'll get you a glass.
Shure: 好了我们的egoKTV
Shure: Alright, our egoKTV.
Nicous: 下一首
Nicous: Next song
Jack:
Jake: 下一首
Jake: Next song
Shure: 别下一首了哈哈哈
Shure: No more next song, hahaha
Shure: 一会老底都揭没了怎么办
Shure: What if we reveal everything?
Jack: 下一首
Jack: Next song
Shure: 哎大家大家
Shure: Hey everyone, everyone
Alice:露西
Alice: Lucia
Shure: 还会唱什么
Shure: What else can you sing?
Alice:过来点
Alice: Come closer
Lucia:嗯
Shure: 还听过什么
Shure: What else have you heard?
Shure: 就是能大家一起调动氛围一起唱的
Shure: Something that everyone can join in and sing along
Lucia:想你了
Lucia: Missing you
Shure: 想你了
Shure: Missing you
Lucia:哦不不不
Lucia: Oh no no no
Shure: 想谁了哈哈哈
Shure: Who are you missing? Hahaha
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahaha
Lucia:人家想我了哈哈
Lucia: Someone's missing me, haha
Shure: 哎呀想想想想
Shure: Oh yeah, miss miss miss
Shure: 别普通朋友了哈哈
Shure: Don't be just friends, haha
Shure: 老老在这唱这多晦气是吧哈哈
Shure: Singing this here is so unlucky, right? Haha
Shure: 什么东西
Shure: What's this?
Shure: 你这什么风格
Shure: What's your style?
Jack: 你今天弹这个
Jack: You're playing this today?
Jack: 应该有很多什么情歌之类的
Jack: Should be lots of love songs and such
Jack: 就流沙嘛
Jack: Like quicksand
Jack: 爱情好像流沙
Jack: Love is like quicksand
Jack: 不复挣扎嘛
Jack: No more struggling
Lucia:出现
Lucia: Appearing
Shure: 我这就
Shure: I'm just
Lucia:你今天晚上住这边吗
Lucia: Are you staying here tonight?
Shure: 主要已经脱离了那个唱苦情歌的阶段
Shure: Mainly, I've moved past the stage of singing sad love songs
Alice:嗯
Alice: Mm
男嘉宾:有了对像了是吧
Male Guest: Got someone now, right?
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah
Katrina: 那你唱那个
Katrina: Then sing that one
Jack: 那那那来点甜甜的吧
Jack: Let's have something sweet
Katrina: 你唱那个
Katrina: Sing that one
Katrina: 恋爱ING吧反正你也是恋爱ING
Katrina: Love ING since you're in love ING anyway
Shure: 恋爱ING的词是什么来着
Shure: What's the word for "in love"?
Shure: 那那有点唱不上去
Shure: That part is a bit hard to sing.
男嘉宾:情非得已
Male Guest: It's "Qing Fei De Yi".
Alice:咋啦
Alice: What's up?
刘婷:快跟人亲热亲热快点
Liu Ting: Hurry up and get closer to each other, quickly.
Katrina: 情非得已也行
Katrina: "Qing Fei De Yi" works too.
男嘉宾:有何不可
Male Guest: Why not?
Katrina: 唱素颜吧
Katrina: Sing "Plain Face".
Alice:我鞋呢
Alice: Where's my shoe?
Katrina: 对着你女朋友唱素颜
Katrina: Sing "Plain Face" to your girlfriend.
Jake:哎唱素颜了
Jake: Hey, sing "Plain Face".
Alice:我这人不爱穿鞋有什么毛病
Alice: I don't like wearing shoes, what's the problem?
Katrina: 你女朋友给你唱那个
Katrina: Your girlfriend will sing that to you.
Katrina: 她唱女生不
Katrina: Does she sing the female part?
男嘉宾:来点那什么小小那个
Male Guest: Can you do a little bit of that?
Alice:我又不脚臭
Alice: It's not like my feet stink.
Shure: 来嘛
Shure: Come on.
Katrina: 素颜嘛
Katrina: "Plain Face", right?
Shure: 唱一个素颜来了
Shure: Sing "Plain Face", here we go.
Shure: 素颜来了
Shure: "Plain Face", here we go.
Katrina: 来嘛
Katrina: Come on.
Shure的女友:等会我再喝口
Shure's GF: Wait, let me take a sip.
Alice:我去给他拿杯子
Alice: I'll get him a cup.
Shure: 行
Shure: Alright.
叉叉:素颜 素颜
Jack: "Plain Face", "Plain Face".
Shure: 来给我给我也整一杯
Shure: Hey, get me a drink too.
Alice:哎哟
Alice: Oh my.
Shure的女友:还有杯子吗
Shure's GF: Are there any more cups?
Alice:来我给你洗一个
Alice: Here, I'll wash one for you.
Alice:哎没了我靠
Alice: Oh, we're out, damn.
刘婷:用碗也行
Liu Ting: You can use a bowl too.
Alice:好那我就碗了啊
Alice: Okay, then I'll use a bowl.
Shure的女友:这没杯子了吗
Shure's GF: Are there really no more cups?
Alice:这没了
Alice: There are none left.
Shure: 你能可以只弹左手
Shure: Can you play just with your left hand?
Shure: 刘帅要不你替我弹
Shure: Choiszt, can you play for me?
Choiszt: 我没听过你弹这个
Choiszt: I haven't heard you play this.
Shure: 你弹弹就行
Shure: Just play it, it'll be fine.
Katrina: 你没听过这歌
Katrina: You haven't heard this song?
Shure: 哎OK OK
Shure: Hey, OK OK.
男嘉宾:喂 喂
Male Guest: Hello? Hello?
Alice:给
Alice: Here you go.
Alice:擦过了哈哈哈
Alice: I wiped it, haha.
Alice:不用这么客气
Alice: No need to be so polite.
Shure: 怎么还整俩碗呢
Shure: Why are there two bowls?
Shure: 结拜了是吗
Shure: Are we becoming sworn brothers?
Katrina: 哎这是啥意思
Katrina: Hey, what does this mean?
Alice:让我过去
Alice: Let me through.
Shure: 我要那 就要 还没
Shure: I want that. I haven't...
Alice:你要吗露西哦你不能喝哦
Alice: Do you want it, Lucia? Oh, you can't drink.
Lucia:我不喝
Lucia: I don't drink.
Alice:刘婷你喝不喝
Alice: Liu Ting, are you drinking?
Alice:你别喝了
Alice: You better not.
Alice:小孩不让喝酒
Alice: Kids shouldn't drink.
Lucia:这不是饮料这是水
Lucia: This isn't a drink, it's water.
Shure: 可以可以哇哈哈哈
Shure: Alright, alright, haha.
男嘉宾:用碗
Male Guest: Use a bowl.
Shure: 你说啥
Shure: What did you say?
Alice:没杯子
Alice: No cups.
Lucia:微醺
Lucia: A little tipsy.
Shure: 纯饮一碗是吧
Shure: Drinking a whole bowl, huh?
Katrina: 农夫山泉微醺水
Katrina: Nongfu Spring tipsy water.
Jack: 可以可以
Jack: Alright, alright.
Shure: 随便随便
Shure: Whatever, whatever.
Katrina: 行你两个小时确实有点
Katrina: Okay, two hours is a bit...
Alice:你喝吗 哦你不喝
Alice: Are you drinking? Oh, you're not.
Alice:我今晚怎么回事
Alice: What's going on with me tonight?
Lucia:一顿乱回
Lucia: Just all over the place.
Jack: 可以啊 厉害呀
Jack: Nice, impressive.
Jake:手挺狠啊
Jake: You have a strong hand.
Jack: 要喝好啊
Jack: If you want to drink, go ahead.
Alice:紫棠你要吗
Alice: Violet, do you want it?
Katrina: 拜拜拜拜
Katrina: Bye, bye.
Alice:我下去给你找个杯子啥的
Alice: I'll go down and find you a cup or something.
Shure: 哎呀不好
Shure: Oh no.
Alice:你不要吗
Alice: You don't want it?
Katrina: 那我把他送到门口吧走吧
Katrina: I'll walk him to the door, let's go.
Alice:你要吗你要吗
Alice: Do you want it? Do you want it?
Alice:我给你找个容器
Alice: I'll find you a container.
Jack: 啥也不可以
Jack: Nothing is okay.
Alice:我给你拿个
Alice: I'll get you a...
Alice:拿个容器
Alice: ...a container.
Alice:虽然我自己也不在 我来都来了
Alice: Even though I'm not here, I'm already here.
Jake:哎呀 我真傻
Jake: Oh, I'm so silly.
Shure: 哎哟 嗨 嗨 嗨 嗨 嗨
Shure: Oh wow, wow, wow, wow, wow.
Shure: 还有还有还有还有还有还有还有还有
Shure: And, and, and, and, and...
Jake: 真傻了这个哈哈哈
Jake: So silly, haha.
Lucia:咋啦
Lucia: What's up?
Jake:你也正好壮点胆
Jake: You also need to toughen up a bit.
Jake:对 报应
Jake: Yeah, karma.
Shure: 你你你先溜了吧
Shure: You, you, you should slip away first.
Shure: 你先找一会去吧你
Shure: Go find somewhere to hide for a bit.
Lucia:我觉得还不错
Lucia: I think it's not bad.
Jake:哎人呢
Jake: Hey, where did everyone go?
Lucia:来点吗
Lucia: Want some?
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah.
Jake:哦好这就是我们5天的排练结果
Jake: Oh good, this is the result of our 5 days of rehearsal.
Shure: 我给你给你
Shure: I'll give it to you.
Shure: 声音开小点好不好哦
Shure: Can you turn down the volume a bit?
Jake:十分默契
Jake: Very coordinated.
Shure: 人没上来
Shure: Nobody's here yet.
Lucia:基本上只能靠默契
Lucia: Basically, we can only rely on coordination.
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Shure: 没有没有
Shure: No, no.
Shure: 一般一般一般
Shure: Just okay.
Jake:好好
Jake: Alright, alright.
Shure: 这个这个
Shure: This, this...
Jake:你呀 你
Jake: You, you...
Jake:这个数据集是不是全球独一份 老板
Jake: This dataset is probably unique in the world, boss.
Jake:确实
Jake: Indeed.
Shure: 就我们这数据集的价值我跟你讲
Shure: The value of this dataset, let me tell you.
Shure: 无可估量
Shure: It's immeasurable.
Shure: 我开始学老板反向画饼哈哈哈
Shure: I'm starting to learn how to pitch backwards like the boss, haha.
Jake:太 确实
Jake: Too true.
Shure: 来吧你给我倒回去吧
Shure: Come on, pour it back for me.
Shure: 放这吧放这吧
Shure: Just leave it here.
Lucia:谢谢
Lucia: Thanks.
Jake:就朝着弱智吧那路去了
Jake: Heading towards stupidity.
Shure: 我们我们
Shure: We, we...
Shure: 这个是人类
Shure: This is humanity.
Shure: 其实是一些正常的活动
Shure: Actually, it's just some normal activities.
Jake:哎正常活动
Jake: Yeah, normal activities.
Shure: 不不不造作
Shure: No, no, no, not pretentious.
Shure: 不
Shure: No.
Jake:就 就你不喝酒就唱不上去
Jake: So, if you don't drink, you can't sing well.
Jake:这很的
Jake: It's true.
Shure: 对
Shure: Right.
Jake:对 这个就
Jake: Yeah, this is just...
Shure: AI根本想不到这点对吧
Shure: AI can't even think of this, right?
Shure: 能啊
Shure: It can.
Jack: 你错过了
Jack: You missed it.
Jake:再来一次
Jake: Do it again.
Jack: 精彩发言
Jack: Great speech.
男嘉宾:你说高不高呢
Male Guest: Do you think it's high enough?
Jack: 这样
Jack: Like this.
Jack: 这你 你先说
Jack: You, you go first.
Jack: 你说高不高吧
Jack: Do you think it's high enough?
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Shure: 哎我靠
Shure: Oh, come on.
Shure: 来吧女嘉宾
Shure: Come on, lady guest.
Alice:吃提拉米苏不吃
Alice: Do you want to eat tiramisu?
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Come on.
Alice:我给你切一个吧
Alice: I'll cut one for you.
男嘉宾:刚刚喝酒干嘛呢
Male Guest: What were you doing just now drinking?
Shure: 对啊
Shure: Yeah.
Alice:拿着啊
Alice: Hold this.
男嘉宾:你已经忘了喝酒干嘛了
Male Guest: You've already forgotten why you were drinking.
Jake:呵呵看来喝挺多
Jake: Haha, seems like you drank quite a lot.
男嘉宾:已经倒半天了
Male Guest: It's been pouring out for a long time.
Alice:这有水
Alice: Here's some water.
男嘉宾:嗯
Male Guest: Hmm.
Alice:行
Alice: Okay.
Alice:别玩抽象
Alice: Don't play abstract.
Shure: 词写上了
Shure: The lyrics are up.
Jake:有 有词有词
Jake: Yes, the lyrics are up.
Shure: 呃你稍微放大一点
Shure: Uh, enlarge it a bit.
Jake:呃
Jake: Uh...
Shure: 刘帅好OK
Shure: Choiszt, okay.
Shure: 然后你来翻谱对OK
Shure: Then you turn the sheet music, okay.
Jake:我 我来给你播
Shure: 这回能看清了吧
Shure: Can you see it clearly this time?
Shure: 我
Shure: I...
男嘉宾:倒酒
Male Guest: Pour the wine.
Shure: 来吧来吧拿 过来
Shure: Come on, come on, bring it over.
Alice:我给你拿个勺子类的东西
Alice: I'll get you something like a spoon.
Shure: 来吧准备
Shure: Alright, get ready.
Shure: 可以了
Shure: That's enough.
Alice:你修修图啊稍等我
Alice: Are you editing the photo? Wait for me.
Shure:  一段就可以了
Shure: Just one part will do.
Jack: 你有没有拍下去呢
Jack: Did you record it?
男嘉宾:刚刚发生了什么
Male Guest: What just happened?
Jake:啊没看见
Jake: Ah, I didn't see it.
Alice:什么什么什么
Alice: What? What? What?
Alice:波啦
Alice: No way!
Jake:OK OK没关系这边有个机会
Jake: OK, OK, no problem, there's another chance.
Alice:哎呀
Alice: Oh dear.
Katrina: 我今天晚上受不了了
Katrina: I can't take it anymore tonight.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Katrina: 啊真难受
Katrina: Ah, it's really unbearable.
Katrina: 点一首唯一
Katrina: Request "The Only".
Alice:在来一块
Alice: One more piece.
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Let's go.
Nicous: 小黄 唱吧
Nicous: Nicous, sing it.
Katrina: E了
Katrina: I've had enough.
Shure: 您来唱
Shure: You sing.
Katrina: 真E了
Katrina: Really had enough.
男嘉宾:咱心里
Male Guest: In our hearts...
男嘉宾:也是难以
Male Guest: It's also hard...
Tasha:也是男女
Tasha: It's also between a man and a woman.
Shure: 我不会
Shure: I can't.
Shure的女友:那首我真不会
Sister: I really can't sing that one.
Shure的女友:这首还唱过
Sister: I've sung this one before.
Shure的女友:那首真不会
Sister: I really can't sing that one.
男嘉宾:OK
Male Guest: OK.
男嘉宾:告五人的是不是王力宏的
Male Guest: Is "告五人" by Leehom Wang?
Shure: 对 告5人的
Shure: Yes, it's by "告五人".
Shure: 告五人的
Shure: It's by "告五人".
Shure: 告5人的
Shure: 告五人你弹的是王力宏的
Shure: You're playing Leehom Wang's version.
Shure: 你谈的是王力宏的啊
Shure: You're playing Leehom Wang's version, right?
男嘉宾:这是告五人的吗
Male Guest: Is this by Accusefive?
Jack: 啊告五人
Jack: Ah, Accusefive.
Jack: 这这这跟那个有什么区别吗
Jack: What's the difference between this and that?
Nicous: 是两个两个
Nicous: They're two different ones.
Shure: 完全不一样的歌
Shure: Completely different songs.
Nicous: 完全不一样
Nicous: Totally different.
Shure: 两种不一样
Shure: Two different kinds.
Jack: 哦
Jack: Oh.
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Let's go.
Katrina: 我真的能唱吗
Katrina: Can I really sing?
Shure: 你可以的
Shure: You can do it.
Katrina: 来
Katrina: Okay.
Shure: 你不行少和弦就行
Shure: If you can't, just play fewer chords.
Katrina: 你帮我合着点
Katrina: Can you help me harmonize a bit?
Shure: 我还帮你合着点
Shure: I'll help you harmonize a bit.
Katrina: 就大家帮我合着点
Katrina: Everyone help me harmonize a bit.
Katrina: 我一个人唱我的声音我会觉得很尴尬
Katrina: I feel awkward singing alone.
Shure: 好
Shure: Sure.
Katrina: 我看从哪开始
Katrina: Let me see where to start.
Katrina: 我靠挺好我不知道从哪进
Katrina: Wow, I don't know when to come in.
Alice:吃提拉米苏吗我给你切一块
Alice: Want some tiramisu? I'll cut you a piece.
Katrina: 你能提示一下吗
Katrina: Can you give me a cue?
Lucia:我下午吃了
Lucia: I had some in the afternoon.
Alice:他说挺好吃的
Alice: He said it's pretty good.
Lucia:对我也觉得挺好吃的
Lucia: Yeah, I think it's pretty good too.
Lucia:是吧
Lucia: Right?
Katrina: 我也觉得
Katrina: I think so too.
Alice:吃提拉米苏吗我给你切一块
Alice: Want some tiramisu? I'll cut you a piece.
Shure: 哎我直接弹了得了
Shure: Hey, I'll just play it directly.
Shure: 来吧来吧
Shure: Come on, come on.
Shure的女友:我吃过了
Shure's GF: I've had it already.
Alice:你要吗
Alice: Do you want some?
Lucia:我们俩一起吃的
Lucia: We ate it together.
Shure: 你这怎么D调你知道吗
Shure: How do you know it's in D major?
Alice:你要吗给你切一下
Alice: Do you want some? I'll cut you a piece.
男嘉宾:我从来不用这些
Male Guest: I never use these.
Alice:我得给你找个容器
Alice: I need to find you a container.
Shure: 我草
Shure: Damn.
Shure: 你给我移个调我就可以可以
Shure: If you change the key for me, I can do it.
Alice:给你用这个吧
Alice: Use this one.
Katrina: 这是在干什么呢
Katrina: What are you doing?
Alice:你在乱叫
Alice: You're making noise.
Alice:妈我杀了你
Alice: Mom, I'll kill you.
Shure: 等一下啊
Shure: Wait a second.
Shure: 我稍等我稍微移个调就可以
Shure: Hold on, let me adjust the pitch a bit.
Shure: 你怎么移调啊
Shure: How do you change the pitch?
男嘉宾:这歌你没听过吗
Male Guest: Haven't you heard this song?
Shure: 哎
Shure: Ah.
Katrina: 没听过吗
Katrina: Haven't you heard it?
Nicous: 哦这这这这这个
Nicous: Oh this, this, this.
Jake:这两天来少了
Jake: Haven't been here much these two days.
男嘉宾:不会每天都唱吧
Male Guest: You don't sing this every day, do you?
Katrina: 每天都唱这首歌一到晚上
Katrina: Sing this song every night.
Jake:每天都唱
Jake: Every day.
Shure: 要不这个我帮你弹
Shure: How about I play it for you?
男嘉宾:啊
Male Guest: Huh?
Jack: 哦
Jack: Oh.
Shure: 你这调对吗你想想
Shure: Is this pitch right? Think about it.
Alice:露西亚让我过一下下
Alice: Lucia, let me pass.
Lucia:啊好的
Lucia: Oh, sure.
Alice:哎我看有点
Alice: I think there's a bit...
Lucia:这个呃是不是还要在
Lucia: This, uh, does it need more...
Alice:噢噢谢谢
Alice: Oh, oh, thanks.
Lucia:没事
Lucia: No problem.
Lucia:嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Jake:谢彬竹没搞定
Jake: Xie Binzhu didn't get it done.
Shure: 你就全程在这翻手机
Shure: You've been on your phone the whole time.
Shure: 你在你在后面有什么用
Shure: What good are you doing back there?
Shure: 四级
Shure: Level four.
Shure: 然后你往上移半个调不就得了吗
Shure: Then just move it up half a pitch.
Shure: 笨死了可
Shure: So dumb.
Shure: 哎
Shure: Ah.
Katrina: 从头吗
Katrina: From the top?
Jack: 从头吧
Jack: From the top.
Shure: OK能不能找到了哥
Shure: OK, can you find it this time?
Shure: 这次
Shure: This time.
Shure: 这这次
Shure: This, this time.
Shure: 那我就给你声开大点了啊
Shure: I'll turn up the volume for you.
Alice:要哪个
Alice: Which one?
Shure: 真没有问题了
Shure: No problem this time.
Shure: 哈哈哈哎
Shure: Hahaha, hey
Nicous: 准备
Nicous: Get ready
Jake:你又行了了是吧
Jake: You got it, huh?
Shure: 他又行了
Shure: He got it again
Alice:行
Alice: Got it
Shure: 能不能找到他哥
Shure: Can you find his brother?
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm
Shure: 那刚才不是完事了吗
Shure: Wasn't it just done?
Alice:能给我发个消息吗找不着你了
Alice: Can you send me a message? Can't find you
Shure: 好终于对上了
Shure: Finally matched up
Alice:太卡了
Alice: It's too laggy
Shure: 你在你在后面有什么用
Shure: What's the use of you being behind?
Katrina: 来
Katrina: Come
Alice:搜不到
Alice: Can't search
Jake:你真的懂
Jake: You really get it
Jake:呀
Jake: Oh
Katrina: OK哦
Katrina: OK
Katrina: 换下一首
Katrina: Next song
Shure: 还有要表演的同学
Shure: Any other students want to perform?
男嘉宾:靖康
Male Guest: Jingkang
Shure: 靖康你会唱什么
Shure: Jingkang, what can you sing?
Katrina: 唱一首
Katrina: Sing one
Shure: 这老板得唱一首吧
Shure: The boss should sing one, right?
Shure: 唱什么老板啊
Shure: What can the boss sing?
Jake:啊
Jake: Huh?
男嘉宾:你会唱什么
Male Guest: What can you sing?
Katrina: 爱拼才会赢
Katrina: "Love to Win"
Jake:行来
Jake: Alright, let's go
Shure: 真的吗
Shure: Really?
Shure: 老板真会唱吗
Shure: Can the boss really sing?
Jake:不会
Jake: No
Shure: 老板会会
Shure: The boss can
Shure: 会唱点什么吗
Shure: Can you sing something?
Alice:yes OK
Alice: Yes, OK
女嘉宾:are you OK
Female Guest: Are you OK?
Jake:are you OK
Jake: Are you OK?
Alice:他的手机铃声
Alice: His ringtone
Jake:are you OK这个倒是可以
Jake: "Are you OK" is fine
Shure: 哎呦
Shure: Oh no
Lucia:婧康的手机铃声
Lucia: Jingkang's ringtone
Jake:are you OK
Jake: Are you OK?
Alice:are you OK
Alice:hello
Alice: Hello
Shure: 那我
Shure: So I...
Shure: 这怎么办呢
Shure: What should we do about this?
Shure: 这这大家以后你看
Shure: Look everyone, in the future...
Shure: 这就是一个情商小课堂
Shure: This is like an EQ mini-class
男嘉宾:富士山下
Male Guest: Under Mount Fuji
男嘉宾:哦
Male Guest: Oh
Jack: 可以可以
Jack: That's fine, that's fine.
Shure: 可以
Shure: It's fine
Alice:我现在就去山东进修
Alice:呃山东
Alice: Uh, Shandong
Alice:呃哈哈哈哈
Alice: Uh hahaha
Alice:情商小课堂
Alice: EQ mini-class
Shure: are you OK哈喽
Shure: Are you OK? Hello
Lucia:我靠
Lucia: Oh my god
Shure: 老板来
Shure: Boss, come here
Shure: 我觉得这样也可以
Shure: I think this is also fine
Shure: 咱们也不尴尬
Shure: We won't feel awkward
Jake:用不着用不着
Jake: No need, no need
Jake:用不着
Jake: No need
Jake:用不着用不着
Jake: No need, no need
Shure: 要成功哈哈哈
Shure: To succeed, hahaha
Jake:先打
Jake: Start first
Lucia:不是谁是老板啊
Lucia: No, who is the boss?
Shure: 老板老板
Shure: Boss, boss
Jake:用不着
Jake: No need
Jake:用不着用不着
Jake: No need, no need
Jake:呃算了
Jake: Uh, forget it
Jake:哈哈挺会
Jake: Haha, that's clever
Katrina: 这弹啥了
Katrina: What was that played?
Shure: 他把老板的歌词给弹了
Shure: He played the boss's song
Shure: 这种一般都怎么处理呢
Shure: How do we usually handle this?
Alice:送去山东
Alice: Send him to Shandong
Jack: 不趁着人多的时候说话知道不
Jack: Don't talk when there are a lot of people, you know?
Shure: 我感觉这样
Shure: I feel like this
Shure: 明天他左脚就可能踏进公司了吧
Shure: Tomorrow he might step into the company with his left foot
Shure: 呃
Shure: Uh...
Katrina: 那个唱富士山下
Katrina: Sing "Under Mount Fuji."
Shure: 所以所以XBZ
Shure: So, so XBZ.
Jack: 可以
Jack: Sure.
Shure: 你你在这里的
Shure: You're here.
Katrina: 起一个什么作用呢
Katrina: What role do you play here?
Shure: 气氛组
Shure: Atmosphere team.
Katrina: 起一个logo作用哈哈哈
Katrina: More like a logo role, haha.
Shure: logo怎么这牌子
Shure: Logo? How is this brand?
Shure: 打钱了是吗
Shure: Are they paying us?
Katrina: 唱点经典的
Katrina: Sing something classic.
Katrina: 大家都会的
Katrina: Something everyone knows.
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Come on.
Katrina: 周杰伦陈奕迅
Katrina: Jay Chou, Eason Chan.
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Jack: 可不可以又弹又跳一条龙
Jack: Can you play and dance at the same time?
男嘉宾:这有点难
Male Guest: That's a bit difficult.
Shure: 你好
Shure: Hello.
Shure: 没事看看你
Shure: No worries, just checking on you.
Shure: 没事 不用不用
Shure: No worries, it's fine.
Katrina: 这个词有点难看到
Katrina: This word is a bit hard to see.
Shure: 对你这上不了桌回家的时候
Shure: Yeah, you can't bring this up at the table when you go home.
Shure: 现在先坐小孩的时候历练2年
Shure: For now, sit down and train for two years.
Shure: 哼 什么好的好的
Shure: Hmm, good, good.
Alice:好吗
Alice: Okay?
Alice:好的
Alice: Okay.
Katrina: 好吧好的
Katrina: Alright, okay.
Alice:好的
Alice: Okay.
Alice:大兵打人装修吗
Alice: Does the soldier hit people while renovating?
男嘉宾:来一个来一个来一个
Male Guest: Do one, do one, do one.
Alice:再来一块吗还吃吗
Alice: Want another piece? Still eating?
Jack: 给你拿麦  我给你拿麦
Jack: I'll hold the mic for you. I'll hold the mic for you.
Shure: 这太浓了
Shure: This is too strong.
Jack: 我负责给你拿麦
Jack: I'll be responsible for holding the mic for you.
Shure: 就跟我
Shure: Just with me.
Shure: 要不给我就稍微倒一点
Shure: Or give it to me, I'll pour a bit.
Alice:有但是太杂了这根本就没有一个
Alice: Yes, but it's too mixed up, there's really not one.
Shure: 陈奕迅啊这是
Shure: Eason Chan, huh?
Shure: 兑一起然后再分一半
Shure: Mix it together and then split it in half.
Shure: 我给他录一个
Shure: I'll record one for him.
Lucia:哇好厉害
Lucia: Wow, that's amazing.
Shure: 啊他那天说的
Shure: Ah, he said that the other day.
Shure: 哇谢彬竹
Shure: Wow, thanks Binzhu.
Shure: 终于默契了一次
Shure: Finally, we are in sync.
Shure: 我懂了问题出在我身上
Shure: I get it, the problem was on my side.
Shure: 不是不是你身上
Shure: No, no, it wasn't on your side.
Shure: 懂了懂了
Shure: Got it, got it.
Shure: 跟跟跟那个帅师傅比较
Shure: Compared to Master Shuai,
Shure: 比较投缘是吧
Shure: we have more of a connection, right?
Nicous: 下一个
Nicous: Next one.
Shure: 下一个
Shure: Next one.
Jake:哎别你别你别
Jake: Hey, stop, stop, stop.
Shure: 靠 好
Shure: Damn, alright.
Nicous: 你来一个
Nicous: Your turn.
Jake:对你来一个
Jake: Yes, your turn.
男嘉宾:不用啦
Male Guest: No need.
Shure: 我们有全民K歌
Shure: We have Karaoke for everyone.
Katrina: 实在不行普通朋友
Katrina: If it doesn't work, just regular friends.
男嘉宾:普通朋友
Male Guest: Regular friends.
Katrina: 大家一起唱就没事
Katrina: Everyone sings together, it's fine.
Katrina: 来来来
Katrina: Come on, come on.
Katrina: RNB是非常适合这种氛围的
Katrina: R&B is perfect for this atmosphere.
Katrina: 没关系挺可爱
Katrina: No worries, it's cute.
Katrina: 没事
Katrina: It's fine.
Shure的女友:都很喜欢
Shure's GF: Everyone likes it.
Jack: 给给给找个词呗
Jack: Find some lyrics for me.
男嘉宾:哦
Male Guest: Oh.
Shure: 发完了记得删
Shure: Remember to delete it after sending.
Shure: 别被你女朋友发现了
Shure: Don't let your girlfriend find it.
Shure: 你不是孤优从立
Shure: You're not Gu Youcong.
Jake:把手扳了
Jake: Broke my hand.
Shure: 很好
Shure: Very good.
Shure: 加入了最后一句
Shure: Added the last line.
Shure: 具有个人特色的rap部分
Shure: With a personalized rap part.
Shure: 这谢彬竹每次最后一下叮一下就是哎
Shure: Every time Binzhu adds that final touch, it's just...
Shure: 非点睛一下
Shure: He has to add the final touch.
Shure: 就是除了内我基本没听清哈哈哈
Shure: Except for that, I basically didn't catch anything, haha.
Nicous: 两条进不去啊没歌词
Nicous: Two lines can't go in, there's no lyrics.
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Shure: 好该谁了
Shure: Alright, whose turn?
Shure: 到谁了
Shure: Whose turn is it?
Katrina: 会弹的不就你们两个吗
Katrina: Aren't you two the only ones who can play?
男嘉宾:对呀
Male Guest: Yeah.
Katrina: 点歌呗
Katrina: Pick a song.
Shure: 主要我我唱的
Shure: Mainly, I'm the one singing.
Shure: 对
Shure: Yes.
Katrina: 你点个呗
Katrina: You pick one.
Shure: 好别摘不下来
Shure: Okay, don't take it off.
Shure: 对
Shure: Yes.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Shure: 这个这个呢
Shure: This one, this one?
男嘉宾:好摘
Male Guest: Easy to take off.
Shure: 那如果摘不下来呢
Shure: What if it doesn't come off?
男嘉宾:好摘
Male Guest: Easy to take off.
Shure: 哦只要不丢就行
Shure: Oh, as long as you don't lose it.
Shure: 但是手指手指可以去是吧
Shure: But fingers can go, right?
Nicous: 这什么
Nicous: What's this?
Shure: 淘汰
Shure: Elimination.
Katrina: 前面怎么唱来着
Katrina: How did the front part go?
Shure: 这也不能顶
Shure: This can't top it.
Shure: 那我那我先摘一个
Shure: Then I'll take one off first.
Shure: 摘不下来的时候
Shure: When it doesn't come off.
Shure的女友:哎呀别别别别别
Shure's GF: Oh no, don't, don't, don't.
Shure: 到时候跟我妈妈哭
Shure: Later, I'll cry to my mom.
Shure: 妈妈你看
Shure: Mom, look.
Shure: 他把我这个戒指抢走还摘不下来
Shure: He took my ring and can't take it off.
Shure: 妈给他剁了哈
Shure: Mom, chop it off for him.
Shure的女友:我知道不能丢
Shure's GF: I know I can't lose it.
Shure: 好好好
Shure: Alright, alright.
Shure的女友:这个丢了我真哭给你看
Shure's GF: If I lose it, I'll really cry for you to see.
Shure: 我知道我知道
Shure: I know, I know.
Katrina: 受不了了
Katrina: Can't stand it anymore.
Katrina: 这对小情侣
Katrina: This couple.
Katrina: 我怎么看不清词啊
Katrina: Why can't I see the lyrics clearly?
Shure: 几天怎么这么爱我
Shure: Why do you love me so much these days?
Shure: 多爽啊
Shure: So cool.
Shure: 还每天能拿300块
Shure: And I can get 300 bucks every day.
Shure的女友:没有其实每个周末跟你出去玩的话
Shure's GF: Actually, if we go out every weekend...
Katrina: 直接拍情侣写真了
Katrina: Just go take couple photos directly.
Shure的女友:会是在正常生活中
Shure's GF: It will be in normal life.
Jake:草 这他妈怎么起来
Jake: Damn, how the hell do we get up?
Shure的女友:然后出现一点很失去的情况
Shure's GF: Then something really sad happened
Shure的女友:但是特别好
Shure's GF: But it's actually great
Shure的女友:只要我正常生活也没有什么很好的
Shure's GF: As long as I live a normal life, there's nothing too great
Alice:是的
Alice: Yes.
Katrina: 哎  哎哟什么时候我也有男朋友
Katrina: Hey, when will I have a boyfriend too?
Shure: 无妨
Shure: No worries.
Katrina: 拍一个哈哈哈
Katrina: Take a picture, hahaha
Lucia:前面那些歌我都没听过
Lucia: I've never heard those songs before
Alice:你应该不怎么听中文歌吧
Alice: You probably don't listen to Chinese songs much, right?
Lucia:我听得比较少
Lucia: I don't listen to them often
Lucia:因为我有几个很喜欢的歌手
Lucia: Because I have a few favorite singers
Shure的女友:就你知道他们在那找吗
Shure's GF: Do you know where to find them?
Lucia:然后听他们听的比较多
Lucia: So I listen to their songs a lot
Shure的女友:我上回跟Darry和顾老师
Shure's GF: Last time I went singing with Darry and Mr. Gu
Lucia:所以留下的听别的歌的时间就很少
Lucia: So there's not much time left to listen to other songs
Shure的女友:两个人去唱歌玩
Shure's GF: You knew about that day too
Shure的女友:那天你也知道
Shure's GF: What happened?
Jake:走道没了
Jake: The path disappeared
Shure的女友:然后就是我说陈奕迅OK这首
Shure's GF: Then I said Eason Chan is OK, this song
Shure的女友:然后他们跟我说
Shure's GF: Then they told me
Alice:有点困了
Alice: I'm a bit sleepy
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha
Shure的女友:就是我找那种
Shure's GF: Just like I found that kind
Lucia:发现无法融入歌单
Lucia: I realized I couldn't fit into the playlist
Shure的女友:我感觉大家都会唱的歌
Shure's GF: I feel like everyone can sing these songs
Lucia:变得I了起来
Lucia: It became a bit awkward
Shure的女友:他说OK这一首我好像知道
Shure's GF: He said OK, this song I might know
Alice:没事你本来就I 无所谓
Alice: It's fine, you were awkward anyway, doesn't matter
Shure的女友:但是我不会唱
Shure's GF: But I can't sing it
Katrina: 周杰伦还有什么歌
Katrina: What other songs does Jay Chou have?
Shure的女友:然后你在说什么
Shure's GF: Then what are you talking about?
Shure的女友:那你为什么要找粤语歌
Shure's GF: Why do you want to find Cantonese songs?
Shure的女友:你找粤语歌
Shure's GF: Find Cantonese songs
Shure的女友:你不找伊森的歌
Shure's GF: Don't find Eason's songs
Shure的女友:什么东西
Shure's GF: What?
Shure的女友:最后唱的什么
Shure's GF: What was the last song we sang?
Shure的女友:就是反正大家会唱粤语歌
Shure's GF: Everyone knows Cantonese songs
Shure的女友:但是唱的什么我也不知道
Shure's GF: But I don't know what we sang
Shure的女友:忘记了忘记了
Shure's GF: Forgot, forgot
Shure: 东北人有自己的一套粤语体系
Shure: Northeastern people have their own Cantonese system.
Shure: 知道吗哈哈哈哈
Shure: You know that? Hahaha.
Shure的女友:不是啊戴瑞家山西的啊
Shure's GF: No, but Dairui is from Shanxi.
Lucia:好可爱
Lucia: So cute.
Alice:他没带走
女嘉宾:戴瑞是山西人
Female Guest: Dairui is from Shanxi.
Katrina: 这我也听过
Katrina: I've heard that too.
Katrina: 这不是高中的时候
Katrina: Wasn't that in high school?
Shure的女友:我忘了山西哪里了
Shure's GF: I forgot which part of Shanxi.
Shure的女友:但反正是山西人
Shure's GF: But he's from Shanxi.
Lucia:不要拆散我们的小狗cp
Lucia: Don't break up our puppy couple.
Katrina: 听的诗班淡淡的
Katrina: The choir sounds so soothing.
Lucia:刚好
Lucia: Just right.
Alice:那狗子CP
Alice: That puppy couple.
Lucia:狗子CP嗯
Lucia: Puppy couple, yeah.
Lucia:好可爱真可爱这花花也做得好好
Lucia: So cute, really cute. This flower arrangement is done so well.
Alice:你可以把这个头拆走
Alice: You can take this head off.
Katrina: 哈哈这首好适合吉他弹
Katrina: Haha, this song is perfect for guitar.
Lucia:我去找一个你拆
Lucia: I'll go find one, you can take it apart.
Alice:谢谢
Alice: Thanks.
Lucia:啊 谢谢
Lucia: Ah, thanks.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Yeah.
Alice:没事你喜欢的话你拿走也行
Alice: It's fine, if you like it, you can take it.
Shure的女友:啊就是拍卖的拍品
Shure的女友:已经不属于他的买家了是吗
Shure's GF: It's no longer the buyer's, right?
Jack: 对呀
Jack: Yeah.
Alice:对
Alice: Right.
Lucia:对对
Lucia: Yeah, yeah.
Jack: 啊好过分啊
Jack: Ah, that's so mean.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Alice:困了有点
Alice: I'm a bit sleepy.
Alice:我真的困了
Alice: I'm really sleepy.
Shure: 自已倒啊
Shure: Pour it yourself.
Shure的女友:气泡水和朗姆其实还可以
Shure's GF: Sparkling water and rum are actually okay.
Shure: 洗发水应该买的
Shure: Shampoo should be bought.
Shure的女友:但我感觉
Shure's GF: But I feel...
Shure的女友:我感觉它最好
Shure's GF: I feel it's the best...
Shure的女友:其实是伏特加是最好的
Shure's GF: Actually, vodka is the best.
Shure的女友:但是不知道为什么你们没买
Shure's GF: But I don't know why you didn't buy it.
Shure: 我有半瓶一直说要带来的
Shure: I have half a bottle, always said I'd bring it.
Shure: 一直谁过来的时候都忘了带
Shure的女友:像罗舒兰这种东西
Shure的女友:我觉得他只适合做少婷
但Shure的女友:你买一瓶罗舒兰
Shure的女友:我其实不是很不是很理解
Shure的女友:不是很理解就是这种
他虽然那个入口特别好
Shure的女友:但是他他对我来说只适合做绍兴
Shure的女友:前几年真的挺流行
Shure的女友:真的
Shure的女友:但是但是
Shure的女友:在网易云的那个归类里面
Shure的女友:功德被归到了说唱
Shure的女友:i mean the why
Shure: 因为他有他有关联的
Shure: 比如说像豆芽这种课
Shure的女友:可能all right
Shure: rap是多吧
Shure: 又开始了
Shure的女友:对对对
Shure's GF: Yes, yes, exactly.
Shure的女友:但他不是他不是
Shure's GF: But he isn’t, he isn’t.
Shure的女友:他真的不是
Shure's GF: He really isn’t.
Shure的女友:你可以把归到任何一个类
Shure's GF: You can categorize it in any genre.
Shure的女友:就是甚至你把归到华语大流行都行
Shure's GF: You could even call it Mandarin pop.
Shure的女友:但他真的不是说唱
Shure's GF: But it’s definitely not rap.
Shure的女友:其实你可以把我背到口中
Shure's GF: Actually, you can recite it to me.
Shure的女友:我也不知道
Shure's GF: I don't know either.
Shure的女友:音乐人的乐园
Shure's GF: A paradise for musicians.
Shure: 谁知道
Shure: Who knows.
Alice:我看着拉炼我呢
Alice: I’m looking at my zipper.
Lucia:噢
Lucia: Oh.
Alice:我一定看好吗
Alice: I have to look, okay?
Alice:我一定看啊
Alice: I have to look.
Alice:结束了吗还是什么
Alice: Is it over or what?
Alice:这是干嘛
Alice: What is this?
Alice:什么环节
Alice: What’s this segment?
Lucia:无法融入歌单
Lucia: Can’t fit into the playlist.
Lucia:大部分都没听过
Lucia: Haven’t heard most of it.
Shure: 你不是怕被踢了
Shure: Aren't you afraid of getting kicked out?
Alice:什么刘婷要唱凤凰传奇
Alice: What? Liu Ting is going to sing Phoenix Legend?
Shure的女友:高了高了高了
Shure's GF: Higher, higher, higher.
Lucia:没有谱子
Lucia: There's no sheet music.
Lucia:可是伴奏同学依然会弹
Lucia: But our accompanist can still play it.
Jack: 果然这个歌词你不会了
Jack: As expected, you don't know the lyrics.
Alice:后面不会了
Alice: I don't know the rest.
Jack: 找一下词好吗
Jack: Can you find the lyrics?
Shure的女友:啊不这种歌只要记住副歌就行
Shure's GF: Ah no, for this kind of song, just remember the chorus.
Alice:凤凰传奇上
Alice: Phoenix Legend on.
刘婷:我其实也不太会唱
Liu Ting: I actually don't sing it that well.
Jake:再找一个再找一个
Jake: Find another one, find another one.
Jack: 除了副歌的词一遍也记不住
Jack: Aside from the chorus, I can't remember the lyrics at all.
刘婷:主要是上吧
Liu Ting: The main thing is to go for it.
Alice:上吧上吧
Alice: Go for it, go for it.
刘婷:图个氛围
Liu Ting: Just for the atmosphere.
刘婷:不是我会
Liu Ting: It's not that I can sing it well.
Shure: 不我们有
Shure: No, we have...
Shure: 我们有全民k歌这个软件的
Shure: We have that karaoke software.
Shure: 你知道吗
Shure: You know?
Jack: 分分钟需要你
Jack: "Minutes Need You"
男嘉宾:都不太会唱
Male Guest: No one really knows how to sing.
Shure的女友:啊不刚刚他就在啊
Shure's GF: Ah no, he was just there.
Shure的女友:刚刚还跟我说说为什么不能唱那个啊
Shure's GF: He just told me why we can't sing that one.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Shure的女友:就是就是就是
Shure's GF: Yes, yes, yes.
Shure: 我们有有有
Shure: We have, have, have...
Shure: 全民k歌的
Shure: That karaoke software.
Jack: 为什么没有唱吧之类的
Jack: Why don't we have something like "Sing It"?
Shure: 来来来我们是有的
Shure: Come on, we do have it.
Shure: 大家
Shure: Everyone.
Jack: 吉他这边就自个看
Jack: The guitar part, just watch yourself.
Jack: 然后我们另外一个手机
Jack: And then we'll use another phone.
Jack: 放在KTV的那个
Jack: Put it on the KTV machine.
男嘉宾:对对对来吧
Male Guest: Yeah, yeah, let's do it.
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Let's do it.
Shure: 我们其实早就为了这个k歌程序的啊
Shure: We've actually prepared for this karaoke program.
Lucia:开始录8%居然就可以了
Lucia: Starting recording at 8% is actually fine.
Jake:对 5%以上应该是
Jake: Yeah, it should be above 5%.
Lucia:哎不愧是领导
Lucia: Wow, as expected from the boss.
Alice:哎这眼镜感觉损耗了
Alice: Hey, these glasses seem worn out.
Alice:就是这几天发现充着电还是耗电
Alice: I noticed that even when charging, the battery still drains.
Lucia:对刚开始我觉得差
Lucia: Yeah, at first I thought it was bad.
Alice:尊嘟 真
Alice: Really?
Jake:随便损
Jake: It wears out easily.
Alice:真的吗
Alice: Really?
Alice:这个如果用坏了不还要买新的吗
Alice: If it breaks, don't we have to buy a new one?
Lucia:没事这捐给他们了
Lucia: It's fine, we donated these.
Lucia:哦
Lucia: Oh.
Jake:咱们咱项目要不
Jake: Should we, should our project...
Jack: 老板不差钱
Jack: The boss isn't short on money.
Jake:主要是捐的
Jake: It's mostly donations.
Jake:就主要是这批货只要不用坏就能用
Jake: As long as this batch doesn't break, we can use them.
Jake:咱下一批就下一批
Jake: We'll just move on to the next batch.
Alice:等于说你想用新的呗
Alice: So, you want to use new ones?
Jake:也不是也不是
Jake: Not really, not really.
Alice:这是可以录的吗
Alice: Can this be recorded?
Jack: 已经录下了
Jack: It's already recording.
Lucia:咦确实就算我们眼镜没开过pro也开了
Shure: 我们
Shure: We...
Alice:就是一直通着电之后还是一个那啥
Alice: So, even when charging continuously, it's still the same.
Jake:噢
Jake: Oh.
Lucia:对他还是会断我觉得
Lucia: Yeah, it still stops, I think.
Lucia:前两天没这样
Lucia: It wasn't like this a few days ago.
Alice:一边进水一边放水还是放的快
Alice: It's like water flowing in and out at the same time, but it's draining faster.
Lucia:什么小学数学题
Lucia: What kind of elementary school math problem is this?
Jack: 没事 漏得快没关系
Jack: It's fine, it doesn't matter if it leaks quickly.
Alice:小学数学题
Alice: Elementary school math problem.
Jake:挺好挺好
Jake: Pretty good, pretty good.
Jake:就把它就是
Jake: Just...
Jake:最大的价值是吧 剥削掉
Jake: Just maximize its value, right? Exploit it fully.
Jake:我们剥削眼镜最大的价值
Jake: We maximize the value of these glasses.
Lucia:你这是给眼镜配了个劳动力吧
Lucia: You just gave these glasses labor, huh?
Lucia:入职的时候公司给配发那个
Lucia: When we joined, the company issued those.
Lucia:叫什么麦克
Lucia: What were they called, Mic?
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia:给麦克配了个劳动力
Lucia: Got a labor force for Mike.
Jake:我觉得就是夜里一辆奔驰就帅
Jake: I think a Benz at night just looks cool.
Lucia:酷 很赛博朋克
Lucia: Cool, very cyberpunk.
Jake:对 就是
Jake: Yeah, exactly.
Jake:穿长裙然后亮了灯就太帅了
Jake: Wearing a long dress with the lights on is just too cool.
Lucia:我们这外面要收拾一下么
Lucia: Should we tidy up outside a bit?
Lucia:哎呀感觉其实每次
Lucia: Oh, it feels like every time...
Alice:都剩一点
Alice: There's always a bit left.
Lucia:对就算有剩的收拾了吃剩的吧
Lucia: Yeah, even if there's leftover, let's clean up and eat the leftovers.
Lucia:也不够再再点的话又多了
Lucia: But if we order more, it's too much again.
Jake:不要丢掉全都丢掉
Jake: Don't throw it away, throw it all away.
Alice:老板不差钱
Alice: The boss isn't short of money.
Lucia:不亏是老板
Jake:还能怎么办嘛
Jake: What else can we do?
Jake:收起来有什么用
Jake: What's the point of saving it?
Lucia:这是什么呀这是
Lucia: What is this?
Jake:花甲
Jake: Clams.
Alice:这是估计被那个饼挡着了
Alice: It was probably blocked by the pancake.
Lucia:哦
Lucia: Oh.
Alice:没吃
Alice: Didn't eat it.
Jake:被遗忘的花甲
Jake: The forgotten clams.
Lucia:没事反正也不吃
Lucia: It's okay, we don't eat it anyway.
Lucia:这玩意
Lucia: This thing.
Alice:都都扔了吗
Alice: Are we throwing it all away?
Alice:要不放冰箱里
Alice: How about putting it in the fridge?
Alice:明天早上万一有人吃呢
Alice: What if someone eats it tomorrow morning?
Jake:那这太万一了
Jake: That's too unlikely.
Alice:昨天的汉堡还在冰箱
Alice: Yesterday's burger is still in the fridge.
Lucia:我也想说
Lucia:昨天的汉堡还在冰箱里 可贵了那个
Lucia: Yesterday's burger is still in the fridge, it was quite expensive.
Jake:确实
Jake: Indeed.
Jake:喝点桃汁吧
Jake: Let's have some peach juice.
Alice:你喝吧
Alice: You drink it.
Alice:幸亏我们没有怎么淋雨
Alice: Luckily we didn't get much rain.
Jake:上周也是这么来的是吧
Jake: Last week was the same, right?
Lucia:我没听到过
Lucia: I didn't hear it.
Lucia:但是好像有个同学跟我提到过
Lucia: But a classmate mentioned it to me.
Lucia:说前一天好像有人啊 唱K
Lucia: Said someone was singing karaoke the day before.
Jake:噢噢 是是
Jake: Oh, oh, yes, yes.
Lucia:我不知道
Lucia: I don't know.
Lucia:我不确定那个同学是不是你
Lucia: I'm not sure if that classmate was you.
Jake:可能是我
Jake: It might be me.
Lucia:因为大家当时刚认识
Lucia: Because everyone just met at that time.
Lucia:还有点拘谨和真诚
Lucia: We were a bit reserved and sincere.
Lucia:哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake:有一点有 还有一点真诚
Jake: A bit reserved, and also a bit sincere.